That's why a dragon hordes gold.
It's like,
what's up with that?
Well,
it'll eat you and it will,
but it has gold.
Well,
so what do you do about that?
Because it's,
it's,
it's paradoxical demands.
Well,
what you want to do is face the dragon
and get the damn gold.
That's what you want to do.
Well,
you have to be a paradoxical being even
to do that.
So,
you know,
in,
in the Hobbit,
for example,
when,
what's his name,
Frodo,
right?
Isn't,
it's not Bilbo Bilbo in the Harvard,
you know,
he's kind of this little underdeveloped
overprotected shire dweller and he's
called on a great adventure to go and
find the dragon and he has to become a
thief in order to manage it.
Well,
that's pretty weird,
you know,
it's like,
well,
it's because as a good citizen,
he's just not enough to conquer a
dragon.
He asked to also become a bad citizen in
some sense.
He has to incorporate the part of
themselves that's monstrous,
let's say,
and develop that and hone it.
And that's to say that,
well,
if you're harmless,
you're not virtuous,
you're just harmless.
You're like a rabbit.
Rabbit isn't virtuous.
It's just just can't do anything except
get eaten.
It's not virtuous.
If you're a monster and you don't act
monstrously,
then you're virtuous,
but you also have to be a monster while
you see this all the time.
Harry Potter's like that too.
It's like he's.
He's flawed,
he's hurt,
he's got evil in him.
He can talk to snakes.
Man.
He breaks rules all the time,
all the time.
He's not an obedient at all,
but you know,
he has a good reason for breaking the
rules and if he couldn't break the
rules,
him and his little clique of rule
breaking troublemakers.
If they didn't break the rules,
they wouldn't attain the highest goal.
So it's very peculiar,
but it's very,
very.
It's a very,
very,
very common mythological notion.
You know,
the hero has to be,
the hero has to be a monster,
but a controlled monster.
Batman is like that.
You know what I mean?
It's,
it's everywhere.
It's the tour story.
You always hear meaning.
We have to be more precise.
Well,
that's good.
That's a good question because one
question is,
you know,
you're kind of implicitly moral insofar
as you're socialized,
but that's sort of procedural.
It's just built into you.
This is different.
This is also becoming conscious of it
and expanding out your personality into
dimensions that it wouldn't normally
occupy.
So did.
This happens to people all the time.
So for example,
lots of my clients,
my clinical clients are too agreeable
and they're generally women because
women are more agreeable than men,
but always because I've had agreeable
man,
his clients as well and what happens is
they,
they're resentful and they don't know
how to stand up for themselves and it's
because they're very compassionate by
nature and so if you're entering into a
negotiation with them,
they'll let you win.
Well,
that's not so good because you know you
need to win too.
Especially if you're in an organization
of adults where there's.
There's a struggle,
right?
When you have kids,
you can let them win.
Especially infants you like.
You have to let them win and that's
partly why compassion is so necessary,
but as a,
as a basis for negotiation between
adults,
it's like,
sorry,
it's insufficient.
You have to.
You have to be a bit of a monster so
that you can say no and so a lot of what
you do in psychotherapy is treat
people's anxiety and depression.
That's a huge chunk of it.
Help them straighten out the way they
think.
That's a huge chunk of it,
but another chunk of it is,
well,
let's toughen you up.
You know,
let's put you in a position where you
can bargain.
Let's teach you how to assert yourself
and stand up for yourself and that's
assertiveness training and it's a huge
chunk of psychotherapy and you need to.
You need to learn it.
It's like because part of how you
regulate your interactions with other
people is to negotiate and you cannot
negotiate unless you can say no,
you can't do it,
and its causes conflict to say no,
and if you don't like conflict,
which is basically the definition of
being agreeable,
then you can't tolerate the conflict and
so then you can't negotiate on your own
behalf and so then you keep losing and
you're bullied and you know it's not
good.
Then you get resentful and,
and it's really not good.
So you have to develop your inner
monster a little bit and,
and then that makes you a better person,
not a worst person.
It's weird.
It's weird,
but,
but that's just how it is.